- 30 miles north of New York City,
there's a small town haunted by the legacy
of the Headless Horseman, 200
years after his first ride.
I'm Jessica Hester, staff
writer at Atlas Obscura,
and this is how a fictional
town became reality.
When Washington Irving wrote
"The Legend of Sleepy Hollow"
in 1820, the village didn't exist,
though some of its landmarks
did, like the Old Dutch Church.
He placed the story of Ichabod
Crane, the schoolteacher,
and the beheaded Hessian soldier
in North Tarrytown, where the church
had been standing for centuries.
Sleepy Hollow was based on real geography,
but it wasn't on the map.
Readers were spellbound by Irving's tale
of the Headless Horseman,
and soon fans started
showing up in North Tarrytown.
But when the town's massive
automotive factory closed
in 1996 and took
thousands of jobs with it,
the town put its future on the ballot
and voted to give itself a boost
by rebranding as Sleepy Hollow.
Now, you literally can't turn a corner
without running into the Horseman.
On a single block, we
saw him on street signs,
on a police officer's badge,
on a permit tacked to
a tree, on a squad car,
and on an ambulance that
turned right in front of it.
He's even the mascot of
the local high school,
where the sign says,
"Home of the Horsemen."
Fans sometimes get married in
the Sleepy Hollow cemetery,
on the bridge crossing
the Pocantico River,
where the Horseman is
said to have vanished.
This one isn't the original-
experts aren't sure exactly which one
Irving was writing about-but
it feels old and storied,
maybe because it's so mossy and damp.
Washington Irving is also
buried inside the cemetery,
and is on his third gravestone.
For years, fans chipped
pieces of it off as souvenirs.
Halloween is big business
for the Horseman.
The gas station across the
street from the cemetery
is stocked with swag:
Horseman tee shirts,
travel mugs, and key chains
are piled next to
lighters and allergy meds.
The loudest example of Horseman tourism
is the Great Jack O'Lantern Blaze.
It's in a nearby town,
and it runs all season.
Nearly 150,000 people
wander around the grounds
of an old manor house, weaving
around 7,000 carved pumpkins.
It's a giant spectacle,
complete with choreographed lighting,
immersive special effects,
even a creepy original score.
The whole thing is very theatrical.
But it's easy to get
swept up in the magic,
no matter how cynical you are.
The Horseman's legacy is there, too.
He's in the gift shop and out in the yard,
where a soundtrack plays
a loop of clomping hooves,
a whinny, and a cackle.
It's not so unusual for
a town to rebrand itself,
but few have gone bigger
than Sleepy Hollow.
Here, fact and fiction swirl together.
Centuries after it was written down,
the legend still draws people to the place
that inspired the story, and
has now claimed it as its own.
Thanks so much for watching.
Subscribe to our channel
to see more awesome videos
like this one, and hop into the comments
and tell us about your
favorite local lore.